i want to thank everybody for being a
part of my life and i want to let you
know that i have some uh new tour dates
um i am going to be uh los angeles may
7th we added a show there at the will
turn
uh albuquerque
may 18th
midland texas may 19th lubbock
may 20
and may 21 dallas texas we've added
another show there
so get your friend or somebody get
somebody you love and bring them grab
somebody by the hand and say hey babe
we're gonna go get involved in something
good
we also have savannah georgia june 2nd
augusta
georgia june 3rd and montgomery alabama
june 4 as well as columbus georgia june
5. and some new dates down in florida we
have june 23rd in hollywood florida
june 24
fort myers florida down there military
area i'm guessing
and june 2-5 over in daytona beach
florida
if you come over there bring them
sunburnt titties out with you
and bring that skin cancer with your
baby in daytona
everybody out there smoking on them door
aisles and huffing on winston's
you'll see a newborn come out and he got
his uh
he'll have a little lighter in his hand
hunting a door out
that's daytona beach florida june 2 5
june 2 6 down there in lakeland
florida i appreciate all you guys love
and support um tickets are on sale now
at
theovonn.com
t-o-u-r
that's
theovonn.com
tour and um yeah i'm just grateful for
you guys thank you so much we have the
new gang gang hoodies and coffee mugs
available along with the rat king
t-shirt and that bobble head that bee
head maybe if you need some head
borrow mine
check that out and more at theo
theovonstore.com
today's guest is the star of many films
um
and television series uh he's a friend
of mine
and um yeah i can't even believe i get
to be his friend that's just been and
that's been very exciting
and uh inspiring
um
he is a hero to many he's um
a comedy legend
he uh is part of the fly on the wall
podcast with dana carvey you can check
that out
and he also has a new netflix special
called nothing personal uh very happy to
be sitting here with david spade
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
[Applause]
oh i definitely ocd when i think about
growing up i used to think that there
was like boogie mans you know so i would
like
i'd have to open the closet and like
look up look at this corner that corner
that corner where are we going please
say you're rolling like just i was in
just severe
dude this is the thing
we actually had a question that came in
put this is perfect timing why don't you
get that up
who are these hotties hey theo hey david
which one of you two would win in a
fight
well is this even a tough question i
don't know i think you could win man no
listen the only chance i have at anybody
is if all my anger from my dad leaving
me comes out at once
because it's [ __ ] percolating in
there believe me and i get i get [ __ ]
with all the time i've always been
[ __ ] with as a kid always been that's
why i felt bad for chris rock i go he
was always picked on and you
you grow up like that and then when i'm
on dates people see a pretty girl and
they go oh he's oh he's this [ __ ] guy
so i've had him step right between us
and start going hey talking and i'm like
i'm she has a date and they're like oh
[ __ ] you
and then i go oh and even a girl
sometimes go say come on in with
somebody
and they go come on baby and so it's
humiliating because they they know i
probably won't fight right oh i see what
you're saying and they're 100 right so
but unless you had that one power pop
and so i even told glazer i see any of
these ufc guys i go just if it goes down
where do i start so
obviously i'm going to lose but where do
i start you want a good so i get
something and then they at least go ah
this little [ __ ] [ __ ] at least hit
me yeah because my brother used to beat
the [ __ ] on me and hold me down and i
was there's so much anger and rage but
long story short you'd win but we would
never fight and um you got a cool shirt
on today we would never fight thank you
man you're not fighting a guy gives you
these compliments i appreciate that's a
great cause a great where did you get
that's a good shirt dude sugar sean gave
us these we saw his fight man oh yeah
that's right we went to the ufc fight
yeah everyone loves walking around there
and theo's like this
everyone's like rat king squeak squeeze
whatever he's throwing cheese yeah yeah
you're like
you kind of ordered you kind of walk
like this you got to sit by halle berry
oh that's right [ __ ] we haven't even
talked about that that was next level
halle berry was so nice
and so fun i know we're barely but you
know when you sit right next to him
uh you have to talk to him yeah and i
have to go
who's this guy you know i i do fake
questions i know what's going on yeah
but i go do you think they're gonna wind
up scrapping and she's like in the main
event yeah i think they're gonna
eventually hit each other i go good good
good oh that's good yeah yeah
sometimes you'll just ask chick stuff
just to get just to like just have my
answer before you make them sound smart
i go oh yeah you know a lot she's the
fighter's gonna fight yeah and i go oh
someone's been here before
yeah you eat dinner in the evening
yeah
and then something happened i think we
spilled a drink or something happened
but we're right there and then remember
jared leto talk to you yeah that was
cool yeah at first i was like damn that
chick's fine as [ __ ] then i'm like oh
that's jared yeah he's still fine and
he's still pretty good looking man
jesus yeah we stumbled him to him we
were on the on the way to the back to
try to
go to just get some food or something
there's a back room and uh he was just
sitting outside and yeah remember that
was sitting outside like a raven yeah
uh-huh yeah he was like up on it now
we're more yeah yeah he did it and we
walked by we're like is that a purse
yeah we're like damn is that thing
yeah
what are you gonna say dudes and then he
said he's uh he was very nice yeah and
then he said you did he live somewhere
near you or something he's from
louisiana okay
so that's it i was like oh i'm out on
this one you're like oh i'm from arizona
i heard it rain's hard there i'm from
sheriff joe country i go one time uh we
were all at a scorpion convention in
arizona and was who cares
i mean it's sort of interesting i had a
bolo tie with scorpion in it remember i
told you the other day i go put a bow on
top of this scorpion
yeah and they have those yeah a-z all
the way so we're at the fight we had a
good time we saw dana we saw dana oh
yeah we sat right behind me and dana
white and he would tell us what's going
on it was fun he'd be like hey get out
your blood cups on this one you're gonna
get us
you're like it's it's big it's like
being in a gallagher show yeah yeah one
time he like even had some blood on his
hand and he rubbed him like gums because
you want a gummer yeah yeah he's like oh
this will help a little vitamin o it is
they go all right put on your blood
raincoats like gallagher and they
smashed the guy's head
yeah i think rogan was he at that one or
not
yeah he was there so that was a wild one
man that was a good one there was some
comics repping yeah it's fun but a lot
of people knew you it doesn't shock me
but it is that is sort of your crowd
though
who is it you mean like ruffians or like
yeah ufc people yeah yeah we've had a
decent amount of ufc guys that have been
on here actually there's a picture of
dustin diamond poirier right there
somebody made us oh yeah well you know
it was fun to see him in the back just
walking around yeah oh and we saw
remember who who was there uh oh yeah
remember rightman walked in dustin came
over and said what's up oh yeah yeah
yeah that's great all those guys are
very cool
and uh i like knock him out and he's
like oh but don't remember didn't he
lose
he didn't win
he lost
he came in second
that's right
all right was it that was hard for you
to say and it was hard it was hard for
all of us but the hardest one would be
he came in one b he was uh he almost won
you almost there you go he almost won
and uh it was tight and then uh yeah
he's such a [ __ ] his mitts are so huge
he shakes hands he's like i'm like oh
yeah so then he's
we see him
and we remember we're like should we say
something because you don't look like an
[ __ ] like i don't want to talk to you
because you lost
but we want to say hi but you know
sometimes it's like if you have a bad
set you don't want people coming up and
giving you fake compliments yeah [ __ ]
but he was he was pretty cool he oh and
he's always really affable you know real
super nice and stuff he was um he was
pretty cool afterwards even though you
know i mean i know it's just that kind
of stuff it's hard he's very polite even
though his head was spinning i'm sure
like what am i doing that was he was so
bummed i'm sure yeah and this dude was
good she was at night right yeah
sugar was out there he's a real and he's
a z right yeah he's arizona boy he had
him on here like a week ago we're
getting out there did you play any
sports growing up did you play any i
could see you doing like baseball i
could see you like baseball and you're
like the guy that bunts every time or
something they send you in you're like
the mighty bunt they say bunt with your
dick just stick it out there and let it
hit you in the nuts and then it's going
to go about a foot and then you run
and i go if you can run again
i go how would i do that i go you don't
have any feeling down there do you don't
you have like a little puss and i go
well that's rude
also it's a coach talk because i'm a
coach i'm not a scientist i'm just
guessing by eyeballing you so but i
would i did play second base and uh i
did like oh yeah i loved it i love
baseball and um that's the hot corner
second base is the hot corner second
base was hot it was actually more
responsibility than you think oh no i i
think it's all the responsibilities
short sucks too but but those are the
two good ones but you're getting shelled
yeah i mean that's there's action and
then the coach is like this [ __ ] pip
squeak's getting too much action and
then the worse is in third grade that
the the pitcher went down oh what
happened i got called up
like wild thing to pick yeah
the biggest puss in the [ __ ]
tri-state area they go spurt you're up i
go up one i go i can barely throw it to
first from second
so
and i have one bounce so
i pitched i i was like this doing all
the histronics like stretching and [ __ ]
i was terrified were you licking your
face like do you even know what did we
like doing some of the yeah i was like i
had like a cornhole bag spinning it
around i didn't know why and then uh it
looked professional and then i put eye
black on yeah
i was i was sharpening my cleats
i was like are we starting yet and then
i pitched and these guys were so excited
because it was just home run derby i
think i got 11 hits in a row and then
they go what were we thinking coach
fired there was a a
quick vote in the stands to fire the
code
yeah so that i played kickball
and uh
yeah i think everyone played kickball
that was the last time it was kind of
even
and then i played i went up for football
oh that was psychotic what yeah where
what school were you at crappy saguaro
in scottsdale arizona they're good now
they have a great team
and uh but i went just because my
friends were and you know you do you get
oh yeah there's no puss on the horizon
at all i'm not famous there's nothing
clicking right you're at that age too
where it's everybody's still playing
kind of
everyone's playing yeah and you know
there was a there was a varsity and
there was b
so if you wait under something it was b
but you all started together
and then they put you on the b squad
but by senior year
that's when i went up i think
no i was i was a junior because i got
clocked so hard it was [ __ ]
uh lucas
exactly really in that movie lucas i
don't know is that about the alien let's
pull up a picture of that king yeah no i
don't think
no it's like malcolm in the middle with
a movie
basically well i was a cross between
powder and luca lucas is cory haim was
it
god i love you have a big screen here
this thing's [ __ ] professional
corey haim was this little puss and he
liked this girl
and he goes out if you click on it
football can we watch just a bit just an
hour 10 of it just real quick
and he goes up and he gets
cremated
charlie sheen is a stud
wow charlie sheen and this little carrot
top girl is his girlfriend winona ryder
oh yeah noni's in it wow and so charlie
sheen is the stud he's buddy you know
he's nice lucas because he's a little
puss and then lucas likes this girl but
of course she likes charlie sheen of
course just at least keep it a foot in
reality yeah she's not gonna go bone
down on lucas look at he's like 3-1
charlie sheen's a full adult oh yeah i
guess he's in high school
and the girl is really cute
and he's like a little nerd he's like
have you ever see uh looked at a
grasshopper up close and he thinks
that's a panty dropper but the girl's
like no i know i step on him
and then he's like let me hop in that
grass
yeah they had grass back then she had a
bushka oh i don't know if they showed it
i sort of pictured it i can't imagine
they showed a bush in the movie huh was
it it's a children's movie eh it looked
like she had lucille ball and a scissor
hole yeah big [ __ ] red [ __ ] bush oh
what i like i like that jade of pink at
smith you know what i'm saying i like
nothing down there bucko that's what i
like knock knock i like that aloe swoosh
oh you like aloe polish
yeah i like that aloe poison sickening
that's gross you guys are disgusting
dude one time i remember this guy
through the it was my first time ever at
bat right and we hadn't even had a
practice bro that was our team
and we were the playville cubs
but some of they'd messed up some of the
jerseys and some of them said club some
of them said like
it was flubs it was like splunk like it
was just none of it made any sense dude
i get up there
this is baseball this is yeah this is
basically for football it could have
been either one but it was baseball so i
get up there the guy throws it at me
right so hard it hits me this guy eric
king
he was like had the toughest arm in town
dude yeah and uh he throws it at me it
hits me i vomited puked right out of my
own mouth
and cuz you hit so hard oh dude it was
it was unbelievable he was the best
thrower you know semi-local thrower
and he hit me and i
vomited
and they called a strike
and i was like
fixed oh bro 100
then another time i finally got on base
it was like the eighth game of the
season i don't even i think there was
like a plate tectonic shift and
literally like uh i just slid from home
plate over to first base like i didn't
really naturally get there by any skill
of my own a platonic shift yeah and so
the ground just like went up on one side
and it was like
yeah and so i'm at first times that
happened so i'm like i got a steal dude
if you if you can't do anything else you
got to steal a base if you're going that
was a tension getter though a steeler oh
that's a tough move oh very hard dude
especially if you have white legs
so dude i get out there
and i went for it
halfway through i get appendicitis bro
my appendix busts
i'm laying on the ground
crying dude crying is it after you got
hit in the appendix uh uh no this was
like eight games i was about to say no
one's connected those dots yeah so i'm
out i'm
and i'm just bawling dude it was
absolutely what a plus in front of
everyone you're crying oh yeah because
it was so much pain my appendix it was
like i don't even know what happens i
think you get like sepsis or whatever
something happens but
you know i was dying on the inside and
the coach is like get to fur get to sick
and you i'm just yelling racial and
sexual slurs at me sure queer you know
just like get there all the things i'm
against saying but yeah but yeah you
said yeah that people would pepper those
in the old days it was oh yeah not cool
and it really was humiliating oh it
wasn't cool you were getting shelled
with them i'm sure it was awesome look
at this little yeah boner monkey they
would call me a little boner donor here
yeah yeah look at this little [ __ ] uh
stick visitor
excuse
yeah it's getting very vague i don't
know if they're offensive
i'm not sure if people are like
i'll let that one slide look at this
little [ __ ] jerky loiterer over here
jerky like oh did you tell him we went
to that party is that anything worth
talking about um
well i talked the other week about how
we went and we ended up seeing chris
roberto yeah that party but that party
was star-studded and
dude there was a lot of uh
yeah it was
everywhere we saw matt stafford you see
a lot of different people that you would
never see in one spot that's the fun
part about it yeah
yeah david took me to oscars and so then
we saw uh to the oscars party and
yeah and it was all i mean it was really
super interesting right it sounds stupid
if people don't want to hear like you
see people but you see people that are
in movies or something i saw the guy
from coda
i talked to him like he's deaf but he
came up we talked he's from arizona oh
so we talked to an interpreter he was
he was a stud he sort of got his knight
taken away
oh yeah from the whole incident that was
a drag
because he won it was a big deal and
then they won right after that right
they won sort of close the one right
after was quest love i think one and
that was a thousand percent forgotten
and then they brought everyone out from
the godfather which was so cool no one
cared nobody cared it was like somebody
chris rocco will smith's still out there
he's on the loose yeah is he gonna hit
him again yeah yeah
oh gross but we saw fun people and uh
comedians it was interesting i'm trying
to think of who else we saw we're at
that guy's house dude then we went to
guy who series has a big party and uh
that was a fun one too and when we left
it was still pouring in with
famous people they go to all these
different parties i stayed until 2 30.
it was a [ __ ] record yeah that was
like
not since new year's eve when i was
about 12. wow yeah dude remember right
when we rolled in some dude was in there
just doing blowing something like some
yo oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i remember but a lot of people knew you
there that was fun because you see
people like you saw some dude from one
direction
oh yeah we saw that dude some guy from
euphoria i remember oh yeah we saw john
voight we saw you knew him we saw that
girl sydney sweeney and i go hey you're
good on that show everyone's like shut
up oh i didn't even leave her alone yeah
but just walk by so i go oh hey you're
like but that's what happens at least
you have like a free pass
at those things
because every single person is known for
something right you can say hi to anyone
really right yeah it's like courtesy
yeah and there's no like like pr people
in there no they can't get to get
between you but you just say hi give him
a head hunter say someone's
good or you saw their movie or so it's
funny but that night was pretty good
and then we left oh we saw kim kay right
when i remember yeah she popped out of a
sprinter i think she walked butt first
out of it i feel like in my imagination
that's what happened it was just she at
least said hello that was nice dude i
feel like her butt cheeks were wearing
earrings dude they were i didn't look
yeah
she is someone all those kardashians
they never see yeah so being out here
and
being in showbiz i never see him so and
one of them looks different i mean one
of them got facial sir you know she
looks a little bit different but still i
think she was there too chloe was there
he was there yeah
maybe i don't i didn't see her
i saw kendall my flight the other day
and i didn't say anything to her you saw
on your flight yeah i didn't bore the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of her with my antics
where are we all going
hey you want some peanuts you know i had
a couple zingers ready yeah
a couple zingers um why are we taxi so
far did you ever get into like whenever
you were growing up was there ever like
a um
like what was that like a job that you
had at the time because you got into
football that's interesting did you have
any job at the time did you ever get in
the football game i got i got nailed so
hard in
rehearsal this is why i didn't make the
cut i called practice rehearsal yeah i
was like a drama guy i wasn't even in
drama but i was just saying things wrong
and i was like
when's rehearsal today and then uh
this guy i was 114
i remember i think i was 134 in full
pads but i took weightlifting i was
actually a little scrappy yeah
i've sort of deteriorated since then but
but then i was kind of not tough but i
could wear the pads and not cry and i
was a good jump roper oh because we took
weight lifting as an elective
and i could i could do crossovers
doubles backwards forwards that was
great wow oh yeah chicks love that fast
feet yeah i'm like what's up what's up
what's up in between
and then they're like oh
uh family was poor so i cancelled that
out and then when i went for football i
remember this guy hit me so hard that uh
just like that movie this time but they
just said you to get out of here i
appreciate you came down i appreciate it
but you came down yeah i came down like
thanks for trying i was probably in
practice for 11 minutes it was just like
they even my own friends are like
just sit in the stands with the girls
like you used to and uh yeah god loves
you i have nothing yeah maybe do
something with the church or something
yeah yeah so i sat up there and uh they
go maybe maybe jump in on that bake sale
and help the gals out do the carpet
match the drapes
you see people ask themselves sometime
or somebody will ask you do the carpet
match the drapes
if they trying to see your body or see
you naked
and
men will ask that to women sometimes did
a carpet match the drapes or whatever
did a curtain match the floorboard or
whatever they say
and gay men will say it too does the
sideburn match the
the uh
the nut
uh hair
what i'm talking about is manscaped guys
manscaped has the full package you need
for spring cleaning this year to de-hair
your body if you want to get some hair
or organize the hair
their performance package 4.0 from
manscaped
is the only tool you need to keep your
boys
looking and smelling like the fresh
tulips that your partner wants ooh
that's right they got the crop preserver
um the crop reviver
that bald deodorant if your balls are
bad out they got the plot the plow plow
2.0
perfect razor for the finest shave on
your face get your face well
that's right if you're using the
lawnmower 4.0 on your balls
and on your face you're doing it wrong
because the plow
2.0 is for your face
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code theo at manscape.com
that's 20 off in free shipping with the
code t-h-e-o
at manscaped.com it's time to throw out
your old hygiene habits and upgrade your
life you know you may have a big move
coming in your life you might be uh
moving somewhere moving to spain
you might be moving uh
antarctica
or you might be moving to um to new
orleans or even albuquerque
no matter where you're going you might
need auto insurance if your car ain't
cared for properly before you leave
or you might need home insurance when
you get there that's why the zebra
can help make it easy
for you to find the best insurance yeah
they do all the shopping for you
a lot of you don't like to shop don't do
it
let the zebra help you
they compare home
and car quotes from every major
insurance carrier and they do it side by
side so you can see all the facts right
there in front of you
to make the easy
correct decision
the zebra could save you over nine
hundred dollars a year on car and home
insurance combined
and they can do it all in under five
minutes
show your support for the show
by going to the special url the
zebra.com
slash t-h-e-o and get your free quote
today
that's at the zebra.com
slash theo
so i did that and then i went and i was
a skateboarder though that's where i was
having fun yeah i was always a
skateboarder so
it's pools pipes there there's 22 foot
pipes out there and that stuff was big
in arizona like that's one of the areas
i mean just west coast and
at least arizona had some of that over
it's a great
no money
pastime on my instagram i like all these
skateboard things so i
it comes up my feed
well yeah and also they have all those
abandoned washes and stuff for those
empty washes in the uh those aren't
great they're rough on the wheels
because they're they're not as smooth
but they had 22 foot desert pipes which
are a thousand percent illegal they're
out in the desert i don't know what
they're making
i'm sure that rogan would have a field
day with it because they're just out
there for no reason and then we go skate
them and one time i was trying to get to
vertical but it's such a wide transition
because you're going you're going up
just trying to get halfway up but it's
terrifying because vertical is 11 feet
up and so i got to vertical and i was i
was almost weightless because you're so
high up and then you're getting to where
your feet are above your head you know
because you're trying to lay out yeah a
front side and then my
my board i lost you know kind of
traction so it just fl i flew off the
side from 11 feet up and just hit and my
foot jody and my brother andy they just
saw a little puff of [ __ ] dust come
up and then he heard me go
i started crying
he started crying isn't it bad when you
get hurt so bad that a sound comes out
of you that you didn't even know was it
yeah exactly the initial hit was like
and then i go
like they go is there a [ __ ] sheep
over there
i used to make when i would get real
like
trying to hide the pain too that's the
worst part
pretty through it
dude when you're trying to pretend like
you're not hurt you're like
yeah it's so embarrassing in front of
guys i'm like oh so i
ultimately the wrap up that story as i
was doing the skate park i was trying to
learn aerial axle stars uh where you go
up you do an aerial and you land on your
trucks do an aerial like you fly out
about a foot and you land on your trucks
and then you drop back in
it's [ __ ] terrifying and this is
where i knew i'm too much i couldn't
take it it's too scary so i do it
i miss it and i fall all the way down to
the bottom as predicted
why i'm scared
and then i broke both wrists
and the consensus around the bowl was
get out of the pool yeah get out get
your board we're next why are you still
in the pool
and so i had to like
get it sort of grab my board somehow and
run out oh that's hard
and then yeah i'm like this and then
and then i go i think my arms are broken
my brother goes you're fine and i go god
damn cause we just got here
and i go all right because we had two
hours to skate so i go all right so he
has me to lay on our league car remember
lee carr that old car it was like really
tiny bring it up you're too young show
them a leak car and so i laid on the
hood and you know like on the windshield
like this with my arms out like i'm on a
[ __ ] iv drip
that's that's not it that's the general
leak yeah what the [ __ ] jesus
uh anyway don't fire these guys till
after and so uh he zooms in like he's
back to generally he's like oh you mean
boss hog i'm like no you're getting
farther away
it's called l e and then car yeah
yeah
so i'm laying on the on the windshield
and then the skatepark guy goes hey andy
you got to take your brother home he
goes [ __ ] that i do we just got here
and because we drove all the way there
and we got the car for the bed
and we had two hours and he goes [ __ ]
and my stepdad is a doctor so i went
home he drove me all the way home
flooring it the whole way because i'm
going to come back you're like hanging
your wrist out the window yeah i'm by
the way terrified so much stress no one
of my necks all [ __ ] up so i get home
he dumps me with my stepdad and goes hey
fix him he says he's hurt he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and he goes
goes back to skate park my step that
drunk as always he's a doctor yeah let's
take it out and take a look so we go to
take x-rays at you know 11 at night
i i look around the corner i'm no doctor
i see two cracks down the middle of him
and he goes he's staring kind of fuzzy
and he goes
well let's sit on it till tomorrow and
see what happens i go see they're broken
dude
even my friend goes hey dude i know
they're broken i got so he goes i go
what do we wait until tomorrow he goes
just let's play it out what are you
saying there's nothing to play out it's
he goes ah you're a little bit rattled i
go
they're broken i'm in so much pain but
we don't have advil back then we don't
have nothing yeah and you could you
couldn't even open a bottle of advil i
can't even imagine oh i can't do [ __ ]
i'm just like holding up in the air like
hehe small whimpers go home sleep
impossible so much pain next day goes
now he's clear-headed he goes we got to
fix those broken arms oh yeah so he just
gives me a cast cause i'm going to
school no he gives me a splint humbled
so i go to school first day of freshman
year and you know what i looked cool it
was right before the first day of school
freshman year new high school and
they're like who's this [ __ ] hard ass
wow because you had two splinters yeah i
had now my turquoise quicksilver shorts
might have canceled out my toughness but
i had a new op shirt from miller's
outpost i was like what's up what's up
white hair i had all the components of
being cool but no game i was tan back
then
skinny
i had [ __ ] long white hair i was a
skater my brother was cool
so my brother was cool and then i was a
math guy am i
so then you got into math you went from
baseball to football to school well i
was always this was this was eighth
grade into high school okay so i wasn't
doing that [ __ ] yet but i was a math
nerd
and reading and all that in school so i
didn't have any friends except this
little vietnamese kid really named shin
and we would walk they name a lot of
them after body parts too yeah
no because his brother quad oh you're
right
so uh
no but his sister clavicle wait a second
yeah so i i i i was smart for a while
there and then it tapered off but oh
really in second grade i went down to
fourth grade for reading and math me and
shin
really yeah she went from second to
fourth grade yeah they're like [ __ ]
third grade you're going all the way
yeah third grade is a [ __ ] joke for
me so i'd go down and go hey gals gotta
run gotta run down to fourth grade for
reading math be back soon brb but nobody
cared yeah they have bigger racers down
there too yeah i go it's a whole new
world and you guys aren't ready for it
yeah so i go down there and then i uh
got into
chess and uh
i was spelling bee champ in sixth grade
i was chess champ i was uh
read 47 books in fifth grade did you do
that pizza hut thing or you get the
pizza pan pizza if you read the books
did they do that no that might have been
the wee louisiana area where you took it
over there yeah i think they baited you
reading for food
yeah hey if you can read wolf
it's called the read and feed program
uh no i i went to state chester nobody
got measles yeah i couldn't play and
then for spelling bee
oh for chess
i went oh i went to spelling bee state
and i got smoked and then i went yes i
fell out because i had a
measles for three weeks we've talked
about this the spelling bee word because
remember i got an inconvenience this
girl got this girl in our uh class or
whatever was pregnant right
um this girl helena
and i don't want to say her last name
but
you know sure it's the helena that was
pregnant if you're listening and went to
school with me every story like helena
had a rib in her forehead
well she got pregnant right she's in
fifth grade she's yeah i heard about
this she should be in the guinness book
but go ahead and we didn't know you
could even get pregnant right but i
remember she won the [ __ ] spelling
bee dude um
yeah wow unbelievable and people were
calling her all kinds of racial slurs
and stuff but i remember and she was
white
yeah that was crazy it was just people
were just you know that's just mean then
they're just trying to be me oh yeah
nobody was trying to be like helpful
yeah you know but also like uh i
remember inconvenience and i tried to
spell it and i was up there hot dogging
and [ __ ] and i got hot dogging yeah and
i got and that was it well my first word
was apparatus and i go i go a-p-a-p
and they go
i go you come on
i fixed it i didn't say that was the
final one
wow and they shut you down like that
security walks me out oh hey we don't
want a scene
so
i came back my mom's like how was it i
go i won
you lied to her no i didn't i said i got
[ __ ] smoked but
i got the chest and then
i got older oh so when i watched i
remember i was with this comic of
you know like
i was probably 25 and
we
any any yeah he heard that story and he
never believed it and he goes we went to
this movie where it was about a kid that
was going to play the best chess
champion in the world of some stupid
movie don't pull it up i don't remember
the name and then
in the middle videos i knew you were a
psycho because i'm just watching it
casually and then they're showing the
chess board
and in the middle of it he makes one
move and i go no
and he goes
the [ __ ] i go god damn the queen and
then they go
and what happened was that was a huge as
[ __ ] up because the guy took his queen
but i got it within milliseconds cause i
was looking i'm going don't do it don't
do it
anyway so then uh i had a story to tell
you about
what you were saying about when you're
at the oscar party
it's hard to uh
if anyone's still listening it's hard to
you know look cool at those places
because everyone's so famous
yeah and i learned that lesson because i
was out one time with this young lady
about you know 10 years ago
and she was sort of squirrely and then
one time she was yeah yeah i'll go out
obviously not that enemy fine
but a little above my pay grade you know
she's really pretty and blah blah blah
yeah we know your history dude yeah so i
go all right let's go
whatever so finally we're going to go
out and then because we saw casey
affleck and remember oh yeah we did i
said something so stupid to him oh yeah
that was so great you're like oh man
sorry oh i heard you just got hurt i
heard you guys no i heard you got
married and he goes
he i got what and i go
and then immediately because i'm a
little drunk i go
wait what am i [ __ ] talking about and
he goes
well
i got divorced 12 years ago and then i
have been single for eight years i go
yeah that's it i think
i didn't even piece it together at all i
just go yeah i just try to run over it
and i don't know what sam was sitting
there like you heard the man yeah you
try to back me up
no case but it was so loud too so we're
trying to talk anyway
casey who's also a studly actor so i
always thought those guys are cool like
you know these type like benicio del
toro i like sean payton he was there all
these actors that are cool and so in the
old days i take this girl out this is
the lesson i learned
so i know joaquin phoenix a little bit
and he goes hey we're going over this
thing me and casey if you want to come
by
and just say hi i have a drink whatever
and i go oh
i go yeah yeah i'll come by i go can i
bring someone because the truth is if
you're around people that are kind of
well known
if you bring someone
extra around it's not
bad it's just it's risky it's eyes and
ears where they don't talk freely and
they don't want someone that might tell
their story somewhere or what you talked
about whatever so i gave a warning i
said yeah
very cool about
i bring this lady friend and uh
she's [ __ ]
all over them so hard
and i'm like immediately i go this is a
mistake
and she's like oh my god oh
and so she's talking and then she'd
literally if she's not like sweating him
hard enough she goes
to one of them didn't you show your dick
in a movie
and i was like
this is a little out of line yeah and he
goes oh yeah yeah meanwhile they're
being respectful to me going
[ __ ] pull her off dude yeah
and she goes oh i saw that one
you know
voom or something or yeah
i don't think that's appropriate yeah
yeah
that's crazy to see it
no she goes yum yum and i go okay
more yeah so
uh wow and so then
that she left you for them no she would
have she couldn't i was a ride so i
i go uh we're out of here or something
yeah and then i sorry about this dame
drove over home she's sticking her head
up just staring at the window like a dog
like how it was fun for a while now
she's back with me she's just watching
manchester by the sea on her feet
going fast forwarding this is the one
with the dick in it
so i was horrified and then uh
oh i'm like by the way those guys don't
like you she's like oh they both gave me
their number oh
no they didn't they were very nice and
cool and then i said sorry to them
and then she didn't say sorry to me oh
and then that was that i dropped with
that curve i said that's it you don't do
that to spade yeah you're out of here
baby yeah baby
baby i know that make me put these on
that's only happened about a thousand
times like it's the 1910s um moral of
the story don't be with super cool
people all the time yeah don't worry
never happened to me
do the question that came in about the
oh yeah
that fits in with what you're just
talking about the girl the guy had a
question
theo always rounds himself like oh you
know these two guys they work at the
septic tank company and the girl's like
uh see make sure you're the kid yeah hot
chicks what's your secret
what do you say that you're good-looking
and that you're funny
can you play it for me oh he said hot
chicks i'm not sure can you please these
hot chicks what's your secret will sasso
that you're good looking and that you're
funny
i answered my own question didn't i
all right gang gang bud he's drunk
cheers well he's canadian probably i was
about to say is he on that alaska show
where they live yeah you could see that
well i think that's like gold rush or
something yeah gold salmon
yeah salmon with gold inside of them
yeah yeah uh
what's the secret you think what is the
secret sauce man
no i think the only thing you know
because you're kind of the you're almost
you're not the underdog when it comes to
like labia but you definitely are like
labia that guy seems like a you know
well i think it was more it was a combo
of i'm on shows with pretty girls so
like i play a skirt chaser on
just shoot me for
six years yeah and there's always they
pair me with a pretty girl then i'm do
it in grown-ups
i'm like hey you know
and then i do rules of engagement and so
that's sort of the thing so it's a
little bit blurry because
they go oh you did but most of those are
on tv
and then in real life sure i like girls
that are kind of fun funny and uh
and whatever my type is cute
but that doesn't mean they like me so i
i i'm just no one's looking at me going
i gotta hook up with this guy just you
know them you talk to them and then
maybe
eventually if you're if you're normal in
l.a if you're actually just like
reliable normal that's a good
quality because
there's so many
kooks that you start they start to go ah
this guy might be all right just because
he's not
oh yeah so nuts like you just as long as
you just stay the course eventually yeah
you're the only one just be normal to
them and then you know because they're
not like gonna be jumping all over me so
you just
do whatever and then either you get a
vibe at some point and but there are
some nice girls out there i went out the
girl recently and i really liked her but
she was out of town you know she lives
in new york and it's that's a tough one
tried and uh
really duggar it just couldn't it's just
too it's too tough it falls apart was
there ever a time where you were going
to settle down did you have a did you
ever have like a moment did you ever
have you been married or not i don't
think so no have you was there ever did
you ever think about it like seriously
was there ever a time where you yeah
because i struggle with that kind of
stuff i struggle a lot with like
i don't know if i could you know i'd
like to i think one day have a wife or
something but i don't know if i could
you know sometimes like i feel like i'm
like that because i have run in to that
situation that got very close and i go
i would be scared to disappoint them i
just don't know if i could handle it
i think we all ideally would like to
find someone very very cool
and in your head
you can picture it and that's what you
would like
to have it happen you watch it crumble
all around you and you go am i the ones
going to beat the system like it's so
tough
and everyone's like it's work i'm like i
don't want it to be because i've done it
where it's harder than my work work like
yeah oh you're just thinking about the
girl they're going oh she's mad
you know what we got to do and so
i never quite nail it and i i will
freely admit it's i'm a lot better other
things and that i try to get it right
and um it's one of the curses of life
it's very very hard to get it right yeah
and i feel like it's unfair because i
should get married i should
i don't know i just don't want to blow
it and i watch my parents and i watch my
people around me and i ask the people
and the people always hate each other
and i go afterwards like i don't want to
hate someone i don't want them to hate
me it's just so heavy
and l.a doesn't treat it like it's a big
deal people get married for press they
get married
for an instagram photo oh it's crazy and
then they and then they go oh yeah the
average marriage is probably two years
yeah and that's a year they hung in
longer going yeah we can't get divorced
yet yeah we gotta at least be seen on
the beach a couple more times but yeah
you'll see guys come out like they just
came out of the mines they're like oh
yeah it's been a good week with the wife
and then yeah there's like oil all over
his face yeah and the guys are no
different or the woman too yeah
it'll be like jesus yeah because they
they put up with a lot of [ __ ] and it's
a new world there's instagram there's
tinder there's so used to be you met the
girl you saw like my friend in arizona
he's he's got it made in a way i'm
envious because he like worked at this
place he saw three girls every day in
his day one worked at circle k one
worked at the post so he picked the one
he got along best with and they got
married and that was it but there's no
distractions in his life right it's like
that and he does that every day and they
go out they have their kids and that's
the way you do it and then i'm sure he's
got grasses greener syndrome and uh
and then one girl said there's the one
girl that actually got really close with
she said the uh
she said i'm finding out as i get older
the grass is browner
and it's so it's such a great
thing to say because
you see the married friends and then you
see a little behind the curtain and you
go it's not you know and i'm not saying
anti-marriage i'm saying if i did it i
would do my best yeah i just you're
you're tying in someone else's life
tears and that's
now you're responsible for two people
and that's hard and you get their energy
and their your energy and
it's it's hard it's hard to do
especially if you're real honest with
yourself if i know that i have these
kind of maybe shortcomings or
uncertainty yes then if i know i'm going
to go pin the without even having cured
these or or just know if they're issues
for someone else and i'm going to go pen
you're because you're when you get
married you're kind of pinning those
into somebody else yeah they they
inherit all your problems and uh they
have to deal with them every day because
you've
got on dates like
oh yeah have you ever dated two people
at the same time oh and then they go uh
and you mix it up a little bit and i'm
like uh
yeah i go how's your mom did she have
fun she's like at chemo and i go oh i
thought she went to magic mountain that
was the other girl
you know what i mean and then you go
oh
is your mom okay
it was her birthday i go
oh yeah no how was that bronson like i'm
from france and you're like i go i know
i'm saying southwest you have to stop
there it's ridiculous yeah dude yeah
okay that's crazy what a layover
no i've been there i mean
but now my younger self was uh but still
obviously listen i'm
not married but i'm no prize like oh you
this you get a lot of girls flirt with
you girls tell me they like you and uh
they like kyle done again oh yeah kyle
was just in here man yeah
stud
yeah kyle's got to get i mean
kyle goes
he goes
i got a lot of [ __ ] from my friends
because uh i was dating a girl 19 years
younger than me and he goes but you know
what i was in college
who cares
so she was one he goes yeah whatever uh
that's a funny joke and they ever have
any like pyramid schemes or anything
like in your area when you were growing
up you remember that
well i think my mom was you know my mom
was very tough she got divorced you know
my dad left
i don't think she had a big vote in it
he we got to scottsdale and he took off
was he a criminal or anything like that
no but he he he was uh
we were four six and eight three boys so
it's very tough for a mom with three
boys
now we're starting to come back to why
i'm crazy so she's pressured he pulled
out of college so she has no writing
degree she's being a writer so she had
to get two jobs you know department
store secretary whatever just to pay our
bills and you know just to barely make
barely enough
and so
uh we were just sort of on our own yeah
and then
but she
she couldn't even date really you know i
mean it was a very
big sacrifice yeah that's a big moment
and then what did you ask me though i
forget about that pyramids games oh yeah
so she would get these jobs sometime
where they would try to get her in on
one of those like tupperware those kind
of things and she's such a sweet woman
and uh
and you just see like back people taking
advantage and all that's just such a
tough world i i i don't know she really
had a tough and she's still kicking and
uh we all try to take care of her
because you know
that sacrifice you don't know to your
older because i was a kid i was like why
don't we have more stuff like we have no
food we have nothing but she was doing
her best
and then i got a few beans in my jeans
so i said well i'm going to take care of
my mom she always said i don't know
because she will never ask for anything
i said mom anything in my account is
yours like i don't care how much you
need just take it because i would never
be here so
got her house and that kind of stuff but
but she doesn't want to ask and
someone's like do you need money or
something like
how much
i don't want to open a full account at
qvc because my money will be gone in two
seconds but i do you know
a little bird feeder yeah yeah yeah
because she's getting like every hour
it's like a morning
she calls me turn it on turn it on right
now david look at this
it's a water bubbler that uh like what
does it do she was oh i don't know but
you grab it there's 10 left i go mom
you're exactly the crowd they want they
you bite and they give it and they tell
you the old 10 left special prizes it's
always like a baby diaper that sorts
coins
like oh look at little timothy [ __ ] a
roll of dimes
he's [ __ ] but look at this here's a roll
of nickels he's impressive he's saving
every dump get two things done at once
so that's it so she's out in scottsdale
and uh
and uh
my dad you know came in and out do you
have both parents no my dad died my dad
would be like 120 right now i think and
then my mom i have my mom so and we have
a tough time but sometimes but i you
know even hearing you say that it just
reminds me to like just be more
cognizant of that our parents went
through different stuff and they went
through a different time you know
it was like just a different time back
then you know one time
no well my mom my mom would get asked
out and it would be ruined but because
she would let us vote
no way really
one guy was i think the heir to the
anizer bush family i'm like [ __ ] that
guy randy bush
no anheuser-busch like that oh budweiser
okay
wow he was uh
he probably had a million dollars back
then i mean money's nothing now everyone
has a trillion but he was very rich but
my my
older brother totally [ __ ] blocked that
one really my older brother brian but
he's super cool and we get along great
now but it was just just being stupid
kid [ __ ] but i remember she'd come home
and she was what about that one and i go
boo first of all she didn't realize we
all didn't want a new dad and we didn't
want anybody to take attention from us
so i'm like you know i've gone over it
mom and i think that's gonna be a no for
me dog
he's not going to hollywood yeah so
and then i'm like i go i like this guy
he's an ice cream man or something i'm
like now that guy had
a certain something that guy's got a
certain gianna sequoia yeah he had otter
pops yeah so i would go and give us free
ice cream i'm like this guy's got
something yeah this guy's special dude
yeah so she's great um yeah my mom dated
i remember like a uh the first black
black jewish guy in our area right okay
and we had an easy time and we've never
even seen it or heard of it right yeah
um
and then she dated another guy that ran
a car wash and we thought that was
amazing because all the quarters
oh how fun when you're a kid quarters
are everything you get for asteroids um
just whatever you want you're younger
than me but i i loved
quarters yeah the opportunity if mom
give me something everything's in
quarters yeah so when this dude would
show up just freaking johnny jingle
pants you know just like wait why did he
have so many corn because he owned oh
you got the car wash
but i love that he keeps the quarters oh
he has so many quarters because the
ladies would hear it oh jingle bells
there was something about that it was
just like you you know you were just
that pants santa dude you just had that
jingle going you got a jingle in your
pocket no i've got a tiny soft dick
she's like no i was trying to be sexy
yes i've got a [ __ ] half a pack of
certs
oh no that's my
[Laughter]
oh wiener got two rollies
left in a row oh yeah certs and i was
telling you something about rollies the
other day and i'm like i wonder if theo
knows what role aids are because i i say
older references
certs is definitely going back
certs uh search is going back but search
was surprisingly good bro oh and also
you know what my dad used to drink all
the time may locks do you remember me oh
i didn't know what it meant but it means
your kids are shitty because they're
giving you a stomachache at all time my
dad would drive around in this cutlass
this delta 88 he bought off a couple
brothers that lived around the block
and had these huge speakers in the trunk
right i mean he's 80 years old
he had these huge speakers just blaring
rush limbaugh and like yeah 870 a.m
blaring rush just like with bass though
it was like lost with bass right like
paul harvey good day yeah you know and
just sipping [ __ ] maylocks and he
would come to pick us up at school and
it was so embarrassing dude it was like
he was older than my grandparents by 20
years right my dad was
so even when people came people had
never seen anything this old they'd
never seen we didn't have a book this
old in our school like people had never
seen like it seemed like the mayflower
was showing up you know when he rolled
up
and he would sit and wait in the car
pool and he would doze off dude anyone
just had maylocks on his face and it was
just like oh gross somebody murdered me
he's doing spd farts oh
sinking them in those [ __ ] seats
those seats they used to really hold a
fart
they'd hold it you get out of school you
go what the [ __ ] he's like
my dad used to pick us up once a
like every six months you know he and
and and
my mom
the hard part was
i looked back
we didn't have his number it was a hard
line you know oh so he'd call us go with
your dad on the phone you know she was
never like slamming him but she was like
and i go all right we're so excited he
goes i'd like to go to shakey's friday
we're like [ __ ]
so we all get dressed up and then he
doesn't come
but he doesn't call either you know my
mom's like get in here i'll make you
some plums yeah
put three plums down
but uh she she goes so my dad was like
that and then he'd pick us up he goes i
got a dune buggy and she's like what the
[ __ ] never gave any child support once
so she's like i'm like isn't that great
and she's like i mean kind of but we
don't have food but sure
and so he picked something buggy and
then we're like yeah he did and she's
smoking her salem's in the doorway going
real hero
but we loved it we never even connected
like yeah
as a kid you don't know and then he's
like he gave me a dollar she's like well
he owes a 70 grand
that's a start
so we yeah we never got charles push she
never got alimony and he was just
flouncing around single in scottsdale so
she's close enough if she had instagram
she would have blown her brains out i
mean because she she could hear from her
friends like did you hear he was down
with some floozy yeah and she's like i
don't need to hear that but down there
at the bowler rama yeah down there you
know whatever dumb [ __ ] place we used to
go to and then she
nowadays you're basically on lojack
you know you've got everyone from dumas
that site different like if there's not
enough paparazzi outside now they're
inside now every person is yeah
everybody
out so it's just a getting to be a
dangerous world but it's it it's fun
sort of i guess you know the other day i
got hit with a subscription for
something it said uh
oh it was plywood i'd gotten me a couple
cuts of plywood for the garage
and uh i
took the wrong box on the website
and next thing you know i'm getting
there keep shipping me
just sending me that p wood over and
over i mean just
i got so many pieces of it now damn i
could really build a real bad bad
just
just
i could build a boat that doesn't stand
a chance
but
there's a company called true bill that
can help you out
if you're having trouble juggling
subscriptions to things that you
subscribe for
or accidentally subscribe for true bill
is there
you spend five bucks here ten bucks
there monthly subscriptions often feel
like
they're a good deal until you forget
about them or until you didn't want them
that's why truebill takes control of the
subscriptions for you
it can cancel them with just one click
they empower you to save more and spend
less
and see everything in one space to take
back control of your financial life
they've been featured on the wall street
journal
cnbc forbes and the washington post
take it from jeb d
who says i've saved at least one
thousand dollars and a true build team
does all the work
that's what he said yep
don't fall for subscription scams start
canceling today at truebill.com
t-h-e-o
go right now t-r-u-e-b-i-l-l
truebill.com
theo it could save you thousands a year
and keep the plywood off your back
truebill.com
theo
you know if you've ever suffered from
high interest debt
it's it's it's it's
it's dang just it's mortifying because
you
you're trying to do something good for
yourself by taking on a credit a
responsibility a monthly payment
but the interest is high on it and it
breaks your heart because you could use
that money
well saying goodbye to high interest
credit card debt
is one of the first steps towards
financial freedom
and upstart
powered personal loans can help you pay
down
that hid that high interest debt
all online with simple simple
and easy to understand payment terms
upstart has helped over 1.8 million
customers on their path to financial
freedom
it's okay to have debt but you it's it's
it's it
really hurts
when you got to do that extra and
upstart help you not do that extra you
can check your rate in five minutes for
loans between one thousand and fifty
thousand dollars without impacting your
credit score
and upstart knows that you're more than
just your credit score so they consider
other factors like your income
employment and other information
don't wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com
t-h-e-o
that's
upstart.com
theo
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application
stay away from high interest debt go to
upstart.com
theo and now back to the episode
it's dangerous life's such a [ __ ]
weird thing man you don't need to know
everything about everyone at all times
do you miss the days when there wasn't
when it wasn't social media do you miss
that i i miss it because
well i mean there's some the funny
answer is
lying is almost extinct i mean yeah you
used to be able to lie about [ __ ]
anything to everybody dude we would go
camping and i remember one time we went
camping as a group with like a it wasn't
boy scouts was like boy scouts through
the church it was basically just like
seeing who was the hottest one of the
pastor or whatever you know what i'm
saying like it was shady right yeah
they're like why are we camping just
right by the church like right by or
right by the pastor's house and stuff
why are we playing a game called
orgy yeah why is why is there a glory
hole
yeah why do we have orifice badges
so uh i remember the um
oh [ __ ] what was i telling you about oh
uh we went to church this camp what were
we going to say what were you saying
we've turned into whitney's [ __ ] oh yeah
you know we're talking
what yeah you doing what are we just
talking about you remember
oh
oh and i remember we're going on this
church camp and i told everybody that
jay leno died it was a three-day camp
and i was like man you had him floating
for three days on that one yeah and
nobody could know it was like you had so
much ability
to like um create like yeah part of
creativity's gone because everything
came creating lies yeah
but everything can be fact checked now
yes i have to say i i i joke about that
because i'm not a big liar yeah i have
to say that i'm pretty straightforward
everybody which is good and bad but
but back but i'm saying anyone
you can't say anything back then you
could say you're going camping and you
could be your friend's house next door
to your mom's for a week and no one
would know oh he's camping i hear this
song but you know with everyone posting
and this and that and ratting you out so
but i think it's it's good in a way but
it's getting too much and and the
problem with science and all these
things and technologies
they're trying to like even emulate
movies and go remember when they came up
with this we should do that you're like
they just made that up but now
it's getting so far you're getting stuff
you don't want you know and then when
they get an ai and all this stuff
robots will take over i think it's just
i think we might as well just fold our
cards
i mean we think it's going to be way in
the future it's probably in like a week
yeah i can't believe we lost to
something that we created that's crazy
it's like yeah we're going to turn off
our phones and the phone's going to go
oh i don't feel like being turned off
right now and you go i'm sorry yeah and
then
oh rabbit punched my iphone yeah
that's not even legal and then uh you
don't even have that app that's what
scares me yeah i don't know but whatever
um we got a question that came in right
here from somebody
here's a guy this is like all the same
guy three times in a row
val
david vaughn what up guys hey man i got
a question from mr dirt himself yeah uh
what's up with the joe dirk three dude
those theo vaughn in the picture
bring back brandy
brandy brown
randy
kid rock come home everyone has the same
reaction to brandon
sparklers what is this question still
gone
snakes and sparklers
why do dogs jd3
brandy was so hot
brandy was such a stunner man oh my god
she still is i see her here and there
she's
unreal uh she was half the reason that
movie's so good is perfect casting yeah
she was great uh kid rock was great yeah
um he's great he's got a new song out
too he's got a new album he's got a dope
new song out though i know he's so
ridiculous i go
i go you're such a nice guy why do you
constantly make people get mad at you
you just you you step in your own [ __ ]
all the time because i love it he can't
help it he loves it yeah he loves it as
being himself i i get envious sometimes
he gets to just be exactly who he wants
well he is i mean we try i guess you
know when you have no bosses you can go
out there and just do whatever you want
they used to be the way it was you used
to be able to have opinions and you
could say what you wanted and
everyone's terrified i'm terrified
everyone's terrified just don't even say
anything and then and then suddenly
silences violence i'm like well you
can't get me on every turn like i'm not
saying something stupid and they go
please say something so i can 100
dissected and [ __ ] all over you i know
and it's horrible oh it's horrible out
there it's a horrible place it's it's a
it's a horrible time for free speech in
a weird way but it's a time when we kind
of need it more than ever in a weird way
it just has to be that you got to say it
and stand behind it yeah you know that's
not me but uh this guy joe did three so
we did joe dirt too and joe did in
covington and covington louisiana that's
right boy
did you know we were there doing
anything are you here
here's the crazy and this is the this is
a good thing and why it's such a secret
beautiful little place never heard of
never
oh my god never heard a word by the way
just in a related story did you ever
have a rat tail
oh yeah where it's just a little pin
going straight down the back it's just a
little thin one like a sparkler down and
we used to put that little like kind of
uh
they'd put a little ribbon in it
oh if you were dating a girl a lot of
times she tied a ribbon on the end oh
like you're taking yeah sick this rat's
mine huh just roll up to sonic yeah the
only cheese he's eating is over here oh
you're like so cheese is your [ __ ]
oh yeah i didn't really think that went
through
ah so yeah but it's gouda
oh it's pretty gouda it's pretty good uh
joda3 i would rather do jodor animated
cartoon i talked to somebody about that
recently because then you can just be
crazy because my voice is about the same
but i don't want to be too old strapping
the wig on and being like what's
crapping yeah you know but i love i love
the movie i love first of all i freely
admit it wasn't a huge hit um there was
bigger hits out there i did but just to
have one stay in the
world for all this time and
number one thing i get asked about so to
have something sort of stick around and
where i was like a decent person usually
i'm real sarcastic but it's like a good
guy a lot of people related to it yeah a
lot of people get picked on
it was very pro
the south because the south can sniff
out when you're making fun of them yeah
and i wasn't i was saying this is cool
and everything down there is cool and
there's a couple bad guys but this guy's
a good guy just trying to get through
[ __ ] life so people sort of took it
as like that's inspirational in a weird
way which is for saying a movie that's
kind of a goofy movie but it did have
that was the oh yeah through line so
that's why i think it hit with people
and uh i don't want to mess that up but
it is fun to do joe dirt stuff snakes
and sparklers come up every fourth of
july and
i sell some dodge [ __ ] on my website you
know
it's fun because you got to keep it
alive it's fun yeah
was there ever a movie character that
you got asked to do that you wish you
had done or one that never panned out
that seemed like it was going to be
really sweet sometimes you'll kind of
tell me about different scripts and
stuff well sometimes it's not really
like i turned down big ones that were uh
that turned out to be super huge but
there's some i re i i just don't have
like if they told me right now we're
gonna go do a movie in uh
you know europe for
six months i probably wouldn't at this
point my life
unless i loved it so much it's just
just for the idea of like oh i'm in a
movie it might be you know i like to act
i like a lot but i like to also do my
own [ __ ] yeah and it's hard sometimes
to do other people's stuff later in life
unless it's really good
and i'm not always getting the the
top-tier best [ __ ] so sandler gets good
stuff i mean he gets great directors i
see why he keeps working
he gets that and if he just points at it
they make it there's i mean it's a power
trip you just go hey i like this one and
then big directors go you want to work
so i i kind of try to put my own stuff
together and uh
and then it's it's it's more fun and you
get more invested and
if you got a little bit of money you
don't have to work that hard i i don't
mind working hard i just you get to make
your own choices at a certain point you
kind of get to pick and choose you don't
have to take stand up is kind of fun i
mean you go on the road i've had a blast
on this like theater tour we're doing it
and because
you're responsible for everything so
everything you do if you do a good show
it's your it's because of you yeah and
you're not compromising you're not
running everything buy one you can do a
weird joke that night nobody gives a
[ __ ] yeah it is real relaxed really is
real comfortable i can't believe you
just got in and started doing theaters
recently man you're doing all that i
know i didn't and then you know when i
did my special that comes out
april 26th so the special was
and then i got to get out of here but it
might be today oh yeah i don't even look
at the calendar yeah
but the special i don't know if i told
you we were going to do in austin
and netflix said you know there's rules
because of
covid
i call it corona yeah old school
but uh they they said you know
austin won't go along with that yeah at
the theater and i said i get it they
have their own rules but so it was gonna
get shelved for six months and i go i
have another show the weekend after
luckily i'm on kind of a tour i said
minnesota good comedy town i can add a
show
if this theater will do it and they said
yeah we'll do it so we added a show
filled them both up
went in there and i didn't think i
played minnesota for i don't know how
many years
maybe once in my life went in and then
my opener was on and i was like
god it's not killing i go this might be
a tough crowd and that's the worst
scenario the night before i was in omaha
was a blast yeah and i'm like but the
one they tape
and so
i do my set it starts a little slow and
then i i get rolling but then afterwards
uh bobby the guy with me goes oh did you
see that masks on i go
oh they did [ __ ] and he goes not just
mass
they give them n95s no and there's
that's like you're doing right
yeah so you're like this
and then you can't hear anything until
once in a while they go like this
they take it off to [ __ ] live and
then and then i go use that noise
look out that is allowed so i do a joke
in here
so that was hard but i said i don't want
to sweeten it and make it uh you know
like fake laughs so just take the laughs
put them up five percent and if it
doesn't sound like there's big glasses
it was pretty good shows the second show
was better but i go
it's there
you're just looking at the jokes anyway
and uh
and they were a great crowd it just they
couldn't be as great as they were right
oh that's insane with a man cut off half
the noise but i think it's i watched it
we just we put some clips out so i think
it's gonna be a [ __ ] blast to have
one i've never done one for netflix
and my last one was comedy central so
this one's really the one hopefully
people will see
yeah but i offend people on it yeah good
and after the [ __ ] oscars you're like
i'm not taking things out but i was like
oh you know [ __ ] him you're like what is
this wave like one day like you should
be as ballsy as you can then a month
later like everyone should be really
it's like when you do movies i would do
a movie and they go the hangover we need
a hard r and right before you head in
and they go mall cop came out we need a
pg movie and you're handing it in a hard
r they're like this isn't really what's
cool right now when i go quit chasing
the last one that worked
hangover was
during pg and then they made it and they
go oh that's cool now so
get balls and just make whatever's good
there's not as much balls in it anymore
the balls have been going this place has
been
neutered me and you are right one that's
funny there's been spade yeah we're
writing we're right in theoretical one
everyone so [ __ ] buckle up yeah get
your [ __ ] dicks out are any more
questions on there i gotta go um i think
we're probably good anything else
exciting that came in oh what about that
one gentleman came in in the blue shirt
do you have him
here i'm wearing green dude huh you look
healthy look and you look lucky too
yeah i think with the green yeah green's
a tough one to pull off but yeah look at
this dude
what's up boss
yo theo boy cam i'm checking in from
charlotte fool
i got a question for my boy david though
what's the craziest thing you've seen
happen on set for what movie you've been
playing in any crazy stories anybody
fighting anybody get shotted or
something like that
you know let us know though theo i rock
with you gang gang gang gang baby thanks
cam
gang baby that's the one right there cam
bro
yeah any shootings anything violent
happen
so that's a pretty tame
uh
any fires any
no
this is the worst answer in grown-ups it
was raining so hard it rained almost
every single day of the whole movie and
it's supposed to be a fun summer movie
yeah and it was flooding base camp you
know and i'm like isn't this the fun and
they go one day at sunday they go get a
helicopter out and get like
shots like drone shots of going over and
making it look beautiful and i go god
damn i see the movie i go it looks great
i don't know how they do it like it
looks sunny and fun we're at the water
park and it's
you know 100 degrees and
nine percent humidity i have a wigging
room this is a big story i'll tell you i
have a wig and grumps and no one even
knows that what happened was
um
when we were doing the camera testing
sandler's like all right here this guy
is good
and i go i'm going to be like the single
guy still i got a guy from high school
like that he's still got long hair he's
in the 80s he hasn't like grown up you
know okay and i said if i'm the single
guy maybe i'll be like him so i go get
this blonde wig
make it i look like i'm the guy from
styx you know or something that's down
here yeah and uh
and then i go to the camera test
everyone thinks it's funny and then
sandler goes i want you to be better
looking this looks kind of stupid i go
all right so that we shorten it by the
way it's so hot already i'm in boston
which plays into this story so then they
cut it
and then i come back from the trailer we
film it again he's looking and he goes
ah
shorter i'm like [ __ ] so we basically
get it right where it is you know maybe
an inch longer he goes just do that it
looks good and i go i'm going to put a
little rat tail [ __ ] what did i put
in the back oh ponytail like in the top
but almost no one sees it's on tick-tock
sometimes people figure it out but i put
this i go put this little ponytail in
and they go all right well you can just
use your real hair and i go
how about i just use this and then go oh
and they go it'll take an hour out of
your call time every morning and i said
i could just put this on like a hat
you just put a breath in your hair
put that on and i go i have a hat so i
put one in a
hat
sewn into the wick so it's just all one
thing oh nice so sometimes i had a hat
on
and it sounds like an hour less each day
yeah wow so and i have to drive an hour
to the set
so i go oh i get an extra juicy [ __ ]
hour and no one even [ __ ] knows
exactly my hair so i go oh this is
perfect yeah and then when people found
out they go [ __ ] you could i do that
no way dude
no way dude
and girls do it i think julia roberts
said she did it once in a moment she
just made her wig over exactly her hair
oh she put it on it's a pain in the ass
but i like the jodor wig i like i like
wearing wigs i don't want to [ __ ] with
it do you have the jodor wig at home i
do you ever put have you ever put it on
still every now and then i have the
jodor wig that i wear yeah let me put it
on sometime
you haven't you ever put it on
but i want that original baby i have you
know what i have farley's coat from
tommyboy his family gave me this
it's like the checkered ones on the
poster yeah that's so cool i have that
downstairs and uh my wig i have a lot of
stuff from old movies dickie roberts
benchwarmers i love benchmarks that was
a funny one
anything uh interesting happened in
covington that you remember while you
was there no yeah
no but i didn't i only reason i didn't
stay there is because i don't have to go
over that [ __ ] bridge
yeah and uh covington was beautiful
and they kept saying was it john someone
lives over there john goodman allegedly
lived up there once they told me that
every [ __ ] day of my life
and i go john goomba you might come by
when everyone get ready i'm like he's
not even there like it's a fake story
and then but covington was great but the
hotels are smaller because it's like a
little town but we went to shoot there
and people would come over
and knew me and so i thought oh i don't
know if i can stay here because they'll
just
wait in the lobby you know yeah so i
stayed back in town
at the ritz yeah where it's safe i
literally go hey i'm gonna go to
mcdonald's and the guy goes i wouldn't
go to that one i go it's 20 feet away he
goes yeah i wouldn't go to the right he
goes just go that way and i go what's
the right he goes do you want to get
gunned down i go what the [ __ ]
this is the wrist they go they don't put
that in the brochure yeah no they don't
so yeah you want a big funeral dude
exactly so i always just walked out in
fear wow but but it is you know new
orleans good place
oh good all right well thanks for
watching our hometown man nice to meet
you too dude david spade thank you so
much for your time and you guys go check
out his new special on netflix right now
um or very soon it's called nothing
personal yeah that's a good title
because
it is nothing personal i make fun of
people but you know what the truth is
everyone gets pissed about all this [ __ ]
yeah i make fun of myself more
so i'm not canceling me
so they shouldn't right what if you just
canceled yourself that's the best way to
do it oh that's a good idea to beat
anyone to it i'm done what the [ __ ] did
you say about me
and then i say
you said you were a little shrimp
cocktail i think it's offensive and i
think that's it for you yeah and then i
take myself out of it you know
and then i un-retire yeah yeah man it's
backwards baby it's forwards david spade
thanks so much bro yeah man uh let's do
it again in a couple years okay cool
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
[Music]
[Music]
thought it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself go
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway
[Music]
they just